it's taken a few years but we finally
gotten some clarification or perhaps the
most messed up moment in the Star Wars
prequel trilogy the moment in question
comes in episode 2 attack of the clones
when it appears that young Boba Fett's
is grieving over the death of his father
Jango while seemingly holding his
severed head actor Daniel Logan who
portrayed boba in the film recently took
to Twitter to state that this was not
exactly as it seemed you may remember
that near the film's end Anakin and
Padme are captured by Jango as they're
attempting to reach obi-wan Kenobi
luckily a group of Jedi arrived to
rescue them including Yoda and mace
Windu who takes on Jango the master Jedi
proves to be too formidable for the
bounty hunter who was quickly
decapitated by Windu as the fighting
continues a brief shot shows young Boba
apparently picking up the helmet
containing his father's severed head
looking appropriately traumatized the
beheading and Boba's reaction stands as
one of the most disturbing happenings in
Star Wars history sure Jango is a
ruthless mercenary and boba is a clone
but the sight of a kid clutching his
parental figures decapitated head seems
just a little bit intense for the series
however according to Logan when boba
picks up that helmet dear old dad's head
is not actually in it you can see the
shadow of janko's head falling out just
after mace removes it from his body and
the helmet goes flying so no no head in
it when Boba Fett picks up the helmet
thanks samuel l.jackson we're not sure
why logan would deign to offer thanks to
the dude who lightsaber his dad's head
off at any rate it's telling that
despite the answer to the question being
right there in the film the shadowy
image of Jango spalling head slipped by
so many fans that Logan had to set the
record straight perhaps even in shadow
the image was just too gruesome for
director George Lucas to linger on for
too terribly long but seems to be true
of course it's not like the Star Wars
movies don't have their share of dark
moments even the original trilogy hit us
with scenes like the aftermath of the
stormtrooper raid on the home of Luke's
aunt and uncle in Episode four a new
hope if that's not enough for you
there's always darth vader performing an
impromptu amputation of luke's hand and
Episode five the Empire Strikes Back for
the really bloodthirsty there's also
Luke's merciless torture at the hands of
Palpatine while screaming for his help
at the conclusion of episode 6 Return of
the Jedi
still don't forget that Disney has
stewardship of the entire
star wars series having purchased
Lucasfilm in 2012 a bloodless on-screen
decapitation is one thing a small child
holding his father's head is quite
another what we're saying is that if it
weren't made clear within the film that
the helmet was empty when boba picks it
up Disney may have had to go back to do
a little Lucas style revision to make it
so of course when you think about it
this raises another question for the
remainder of the battle where exactly
was Django's head was it just kind of
sitting there on the ground and if so
was it somewhere that young boba could
see it upon further reflection we're
thinking that Django's head probably was
hanging around for the rest of the
battle which means that Logan's
explanation actually serves to make the
tragic scene even worse well nobody ever
said that being the clone son of a
Mandalorian mercenary in a galaxy far
far away was easy check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]